hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very excited to have musician actress
and all around lovely human being
caitlyn tarver on today's episode last
year she just released her very first
full album called subject to change
which has a lot of beautiful songs about
just kind of being in the middle of
something feeling a little stuck feeling
your feelings going through all of it
which i think is something we can all
relate to uh we get to talk about what
it's like creating that album what her
general creative process is how being on
the reality show american juniors in
2003
jump started not only her foyer into
entertainment but her entire family's
foyer into entertainment we talk about
feelings a lot in this episode uh and so
i think you will enjoy it and hopefully
have something to relate to caitlyn is a
very introspective and wise person uh so
i really hope you enjoy this episode of
not too deep with caitlyn tarver
[Music]
i'm so excited to talk to you you are
a multifaceted artist and so
i'm very curious to hear from you
how
we got to where we're at right now and
also like what do you if someone asks
you what you do what's what do you say
[Laughter]
um
i mean i guess
simply put
i'm a singer songwriter and i also act
um so i i guess i do all of those things
um
but
you know it's it's a weird existence at
times because
i feel like one of my uh favorite
songwriters right now named maddie diaz
i think she said this in an interview
like my job is to have feelings um which
i think is a really good way to put it
because it can be
it can be confusing to me even to answer
that question i'm like what do i do i
have no idea literally couldn't tell you
what i do
um but yeah so how did we get into
art into the world of feeling feelings
um
so
i mean i
i feel like i always have to start it
with like i did this reality show when i
was 13.
yes
american juniors
yes right yes
um you know so some people saw it there
was only one season in 2003 and it was
like american idol for kids it was like
ryan seacrest was the host
we had different judges but that was the
general idea
of what it was and
i was obsessed with the first season of
american idol i heard ryan announced
they were doing one for kids
i loved to sing and i was like cool i
want to do that yeah i want to audition
and so my parents luckily like loaded us
all up and
my sister and i both auditioned
and
i
i made it like pretty far on that show
enough to where it like got me to la and
then it got me singing on the show every
week and my family was like plucked from
georgia and we were like staying in this
fancy hotel in west hollywood
it's like all piled into one room
amazing
i don't know we just all kind of like
see that as a pretty pivotal moment in
our lives because
after that we all just kind of became
obsessed with the idea of being in
this business
uh because now my brother's an actor i
do what i do my little sister is also
acting so we all like got the bug um
and so essentially that's you know
the short version of of how i kind of
found my way or found myself out here
doing this sure okay so you said you and
your sister auditioned how was the
tension or support
uh
post you making it and your sister not
it was
obviously disappointing
um
but
yeah
she's the most supportive person
in my life i mean she like
she was nine at the time i was 13
so it was just
a beginning core memory just to give her
a little bit of what hollywood's like
taste of what it's really like um
yeah no it's it was it was definitely
challenging but she was excited for me
and continues to be excited for for me
and everything that that we're doing
we're all pretty supportive of each
other luckily and not too uh
yeah too competitive and
i'm very curious about what it what it's
been like to have siblings that are also
involved in the entertainment industry
have you guys i mean it sounds like like
what you're saying you guys support each
other obviously but then do you guys go
in on the same auditions for things ever
well
so far
not really like my older brother is an
actor so we're not going out for the
same roles but it's funny because he's
on a show right now where he has a
sister on the show and i auditioned to
play a sister his sister
can you imagine
was hilarious and like i knew it
probably wouldn't go my way but i was
also like wow it's really sobering when
you can't land the job you were
literally born to play you literally
play
every hour of every day outside of this
audition and the true uh the true
meaning of this business is um
summed up in that but
no for the most part it's been okay um
and my sister's sort of just starting
out so we're not going out for a lot of
the same roles yet but you know i go
through that with friends and it's just
kind of a part of it and
you just can't take it too personally
yeah i mean you're said than done but it
must also be nice to just have a
built-in support system like family
that's going through and experiencing
the same wild world of hollywood that
you are it's super nice and i like
haven't really experienced it without
that so i don't even know
it's like wild to think because i'm like
i don't even know if i would have had
the
like
uh guts to stay in this if i didn't kind
of have my family to lean on um sure
your stand what it's like
um
yeah so it's really nice that's great
yeah so you do you've done acting uh but
now it seems like you're much more
focused on your music
yeah
so
you've been making albums you've
co-written with cheryl co or cole you've
like
recently as of last year subject to
change is your most recent uh album that
came out talk to me about i'm so curious
i'm not a musically inclined person but
i'm fascinated about the creative
process of creating an album what's
what's your process like for that well
this was really my first album so i've
done um
you know i've obviously started out way
back on american juniors and i've sort
of
you know
somewhat been doing it since then but i
really feel like i didn't find my kind
of like
creative voice as a as a songwriter as a
singer until probably around like five
or six years ago
and so that's when i started releasing
stuff a little more consistently and
kind of you know
trusting my abilities and yeah just
getting a little more confident in it
and um
but
so i put out like some eps which are
kind of like four or five song little
collections like mini albums basically
yeah and i was just putting out some
singles and then you know last year kind
of late 2020 i
was like i'd really like to do an album
i'd really like to kind of reach that
milestone uh as an artist and um
have that kind of feeling of
working really hard on one project and
having it all kind of be
one body of work
and so
yeah it was cool to kind of get to build
something like that uh
and
think about it in those terms whereas
before you're kind of just
i don't know it can feel like you're
sort of throwing things out there to see
what sticks and like well i'll try this
i'll try yeah
and so it made me feel a lot more like
in charge of what i was doing and a lot
more hands-on
of like okay this is kind of what i'm
writing about seems like i'm sort of
circling around these themes like why
don't i lean in lean into that and
kind of see where that goes and i don't
know it just felt way more um
like it was
mine
yeah that was a really uh rewarding
thing to do as a
artist and as like a creative person
yeah i guess i've never really thought
deeply about the difference between an
ep and an album and it must be pretty
substantial to think that you're just
going to throw a couple songs out there
but this one is going to be kind of like
a thesis statement into something that's
exactly what it feels like yeah you're
like okay i've sort of like written my
little papers but this is like my
real presentation
um and you know like
i think the good and challenging part of
the music industry right now is
anything goes like yeah you know it's
not so much like the old formula of like
you know person gets signed to bit major
label person writes their album for
three years right and puts that out and
tours on it for three years like
it's so much more of like a quick
turnaround so people are doing multiple
eps a year or just singles or
and so it's it's really like kind of in
your hands like what you want to do and
how you want to do it which is like
simultaneously
uh freeing and a little paralyzing yeah
it feels like you i no i get analysis
paralysis all the time when there's too
many choices on something yeah and it
seems like yeah especially with you know
social media and internet and everything
like the way you create it's truly up to
you
yeah yeah and so that's what was really
nice about deciding to make the album
was like i'm going to make this decision
to make this follow-length thing and i'm
just going to stick to it and like just
do it yeah
and i like waffled on that even after
making that declaration to myself i was
like well should it be two eps like i
just
so back and forth but i'm glad i
decided to just kind of stick to it and
put out an album it felt it felt
different it felt like exciting and um
now i'm just kind of like it's out there
and people are finding it and it's yeah
cool you because you released it last
year and then you toured around for a
bit with it at the end of last year yeah
what was that like especially you know
in these times when
artists especially musicians being able
to perform live is
uh has much more variables to it now
than it used to what was touring like
yeah it was i mean it was amazing
because i hadn't done it in so long and
so it was
just a really really fun to be like oh
we get to like play shows again yeah
but
yeah i mean it was i only did uh well i
ended up actually having to postpone the
last show because here in l.a kind of
right when everything was starting to
get a little scary again um
so i played only four shows um so it was
like
just enough to sort of feel the feeling
again but by the
by the fourth one i was like okay i kind
of remember how to do this like it was
definitely i was a lot more nervous than
i'd ever been and a lot more just like
what do i how do i do this but there's
nothing like getting to actually play
the songs live like and especially i
mean
it sounds cheesy but it was like so much
sweeter after having not getting to do
that yeah
here is like
um because there's you can't really
compare like putting songs out on the
internet and like instagram and you know
all the things that we have now to like
actual in-person
you know connections singing the songs
together and seeing how it really feels
to people
in the room like i just yeah i'm so
excited to do that again and um
it was so fun yeah i miss it already i
know it feels like you were just getting
momentum and then the world was like ah
we're gonna hold off a little bit
yeah
were there any weird experiences any
notable um
audience uh moments uh in the shows at
all
i mean i feel like what pops in my head
uh so it was like the first show back in
new york and uh
it was like a packed room it was amazing
and i sort of like when i'm on stage can
really just get
going on a tangent of just
almost like i'm like a st i think i'm
like a stand up or something up there
like yeah i was gonna ask what your like
vibe is on stage that's funny because i
think i a lot of my songs are very
emotional and like introspective and on
the like kind of more heavy side and i
think we'll come to shows and i'm a
little i i'm actually kind of
bubbly and uh and charming and like
doing well why are you why do you write
these songs
i'm confused um but you know it's just i
guess
my thing but um
i was sort of i think i had this i was
going off on this bit about like
um
how
if you live in l.a long long enough like
you
automatically just kind of end up with
that co-star app on your phone
somehow you have it and you're like what
when what time was i born um because it
just becomes very important
at some point
oh yeah asked enough like what's your
sign what's your thing and so it's just
funny because i was like talking about
that
and i had gone to this i was telling a
story about how i'd gone to this party
and there were like
these you know teens there and they were
talking to me and they were like what's
your sign and i was like
uh scorpio and they were like oh
my god and i was like what what does
that mean and they were like well let me
see your co-star and so i give it to
them and they look at it and i'm like
scorpio into
you know yeah
whatever and they were like oh my god
they were like you're insane and i was
like i am and they were like this makes
a lot of sense why you write the songs
you write yeah that makes a lot of sense
so i was just like going off on the
story we're laughing and then
all of a sudden this person yells out
how old are you
secretly just plugging in your birthday
to try and figure out more about you to
see if you were actually a scorpio yeah
exactly
um but yeah that was a funny moment that
kind of sticks out but it's great
yeah it's it's fun
yeah
i do think that one of the things that
worries me is the teens and astrology
combination
i don't know if it's going to work out
for the best i hope so
i know
who knows but
maybe we're on to something maybe i am
that's why i'm maybe
they are yeah the holders of all the
truth in the universe yeah
well hey you know if that gives me more
like license to be
crazy then i'll
i'm also curious i'm at all on that you
the
like you said creating an album you're
putting so much like thought and
emotional energy into it and then it
gets released into the world and then
what happens after that like what
happens now you know you just you kind
of sit and bask in it
yeah
i mean honestly i'm i'm i'm living that
in this very second yeah like okay what
now like i put the album out almost two
months ago and um
and yeah there's very much like a
slump that happens because
which i was expecting like because it's
so exciting and so much anticipation and
you know it's always more fun to
anticipate something than for it to
happen in it
yes very true oh it's sad that i'm like
can't anticipate the album release
anymore i'm like well it's
it's out
and so
but i'm trying to just
i think it was really fun to get to play
the shows kind of a month later because
i kind of got to
you know enjoy it with people who were
also enjoying it and that's always
feeling and and now that i'm kind of
back in l.a it's a new year i'm
i'm
just trying to kind of
uh stretch it out as long as i can
because i i did work really hard on it
and i put a lot of time and effort and
energy and i
i'm really proud of it so i'm just
trying to kind of let myself chill for a
second and be proud of it and just be
like
not kind of uh succumb to that pressure
of like
you know what's next like yeah keep it
up like i i don't know i'm gonna start
writing again i'm always writing but i'm
just trying not to um
panic
yeah no i
i feel like that's a universal kind of
uh thing for everyone to handle right
now but
the songs that you have on this and just
the overall concept of like subject to
change i do feel like touches on like a
lot of universal kind of like feelings
and emotions that people have gone
through in different capacities over the
last couple years is there a certain
like
sentiment or feeling that you want
people to take away from the album
yeah i think
i just
really wanted to kind of capture this uh
feeling of like being in the middle of
something like i think there's
um
a lot of emphasis on like
going through something and then getting
through it and the other side and being
able to look back and
um see what you learned and i don't know
like a lot of my real experience in life
and my friends and just kind of what i
see
is like life is kind of always
constantly
messy and good and bad and sad and happy
and um just kind of all of it and i
think for a long time i
was and still do i mean still am i think
it's just kind of a human thing it's to
always kind of be looking for like this
thing that's going to click in that's
going to make everything feel right or
secure or safe or um like you're kind of
like ah okay
cool and i think obviously as we get
older like
things do sort of shift and click into
place a little bit more easily than they
did when we were like early 20s or
teenagers or whatever
but there's kind of i think there's
always going to be this sense of like
what what what am i missing what do i
need like
and
i don't know i just was thinking about a
lot of that and
i started therapy and it was like
a big deal for me
in going to therapy was like kind of
expressing these
these um stressors that i had these
confusing things i was going through
and allowing myself to just say like i
don't know
yeah i know how i feel i don't know
what's gonna happen and i don't know
like that was just a bigger deal than i
thought it was to be able to kind of let
myself sit in a mess for a second um
that's literally what i talk about with
my therapist as well it's just like the
being in it and that's okay because it's
always i think people
look retroactively at the past for
answers or they seek the future to be
like already over something or out of
something there's nothing worse than
sitting in the middle of an
uncomfortable feeling and being totally
what do i do like how do i just go away
and it's just unfortunately it's just
not
that easy yeah you're never going to get
to a different place if you don't allow
yourself to kind of sit and the
discomfort and
i don't know that's
you know it's not like every song is
like pointing back to that feeling but i
think as a whole it was just kind of
touching on a lot of those themes and um
the idea of change and kind of being in
progress and uh being open to that
instead of resisting it was uh sort of
like what i was thinking of i think
that's great and i do think it's
something that
maybe as like an emotion doesn't seem so
glamorous or so like it's so easy to
write about like a breakup or like you
know the worst thing but this is like
not the worst but it's also not the best
but it's still significant in that
yeah and there are relationship songs on
there there are breakup songs there are
sad songs and you know but it's all kind
of a part of it i think like i think
even if you're going through something
like that there's a lot of
conflicting feelings you have it's like
nothing's ever like cut and dry simple
um and so i just find that interesting
and
sort of try and analyze it and write
about it sweet yeah um well we'll let
everyone sit in that for a second and
we're gonna take a quick break
and we'll be right back just sit in that
yeah we'll be right back and we're not
too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us a
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
um i'm also very curious one
your husband's also a musician
well he was he was in a band back in the
day he's not anymore but but yeah i mean
when we met he was a he was in a band
how did you guys meet
we met through a mutual friend uh
like earl like a year after i moved to
l.a so we were really young
um yeah and then
that's kind of how we met but yeah he
was in that band it was in a band called
this providence they were kind of like
the like
pop punk emo fun world
like warped tour and stuff like yeah
like check vans and everything
yes yes
so he was in that for a while but um
yeah now he
manages musicians oh nice
and who is a designer and stuff so in
terms of
one that's a major collaboration but i'm
also curious artistically
in collaborating because you've written
songs for yourself you've written songs
for other people
when do you
like when you write something how do you
know if it's for you or for someone else
that's tough
it's hard to like
have a
uh
answer that's like this is exactly
universal yeah sometimes it's just a
feeling like
i don't know i can get
usually like for the songs that i've had
that have got gone on to be recorded by
another artist i knew pretty quickly
it wasn't for me like sometimes you just
write a song and
you just kind of want to serve whatever
the song is saying and it's not
necessarily
something that you feel super connected
to or um
as as an artist yourself sure
sometimes when you're like oh okay like
i think i could let that one go um but a
lot of times it's like pretty
immediate when it's like oh why don't
you send the song to someone else and
i'm like no it's mine i love it
um
so i try to listen to that but i don't
know i think
i'm trying to
get into that more like writing with and
for other artists so i think it'll be
interesting to see as i do it like yeah
that will go and how i'll kind of
uh decipher that because i think it's um
tough because i want to bring the same
level of like
uh care and um
you know effort to someone else's song
as i would if it were my own so i think
i i love them all
but
it's just sort of a feeling i guess yeah
well on that note when you are looking
for collaborations is do you have a way
in which you
kind of
link up with people do you kind of seek
other people out or do you look for more
organic situations
it's
it's kind of a mix of everything yeah
it's a mix like sometimes you'll just
get
paired with someone you've never met and
you've maybe heard something they did
but sometimes you haven't and it's just
like you guys i think would be good
together like publishers or managers or
you know people put you together and um
i've done a lot of those sessions where
you just kind of like end up in a room
with two other people
oh wow
you can kind of feel pretty immediately
that you don't necessarily click but
you're not expected to like write a
meaningful song that's good wow
so over the past like few years i've
definitely whittled it down to
at least like if i'm no i'm writing
something for myself i like to kind of
choose from a handful of people that
you just kind of naturally click with
you they already kind of know your life
and your background and um those always
seem to make for a little bit better
songs just because you don't have to
like go through the
rehashing of like well i went through
this and then this and this is how i
feel about it so i like to kind of write
songs about this and that yeah so you
don't have to like do the whole uh it's
like uh
yeah like speed dating it sounds like no
it's like that we call it like blind
dates like it's like oh you know i have
to do a blind date session my fingers
crossed
um but you know a lot of times those
sessions can introduce you to the people
that you love like i met one of my
producers
who i work with all the time
just by being set up blindly oh wow you
just like are in the room and you kind
of
can tell you speak the same language and
you're like oh i think we get each other
i think we have like similar brains yeah
it's um it's a weird thing but yeah i
guess you have to trust your intuition a
little bit on that kind of stuff too
you have to let yeah it it took a lot of
like
growth for me to be like hey like if
you're not
clicking with someone that doesn't mean
you're not good at what you do it just
means like maybe he's not the or she's
not the one yeah to like help you write
this song and it because i i can always
tend to be like
i need to do whatever it takes
it's me it's me it must be me yeah i'm
trash i'm not talented
um
but once i you know wrote with people
who i felt like i had the same brain
like it made all the difference that's
very cool yeah
what are your thoughts on the social
media aspect of all of this because like
now obviously it's like part of the job
description for creatives to exist on
there what's your relationship with that
oh my gosh i feel like it's like
up and down
because
i try to look at it as a
tool that is useful of like okay like
this is kind of cool that you can go
directly
to fans and people can give you feedback
and
when it's positive it's cool and
you get a like sense of you know
what people like and what they don't and
you know it's a fun way to share your
personality like i try to see the good
in it um
but
and like you said just sort of like
accept the reality that it like is a
part of it now like as much as
but at the same time it's like if i
really hated it like
i wouldn't i don't know that i would
force myself to do it because
it's also just like
if i can feel myself getting burnt out
or um
looking at it too much and
you know i can always kind of sense like
if i start out the day looking at
instagram or whatever and
i follow a bunch of other artists i
follow a bunch of other songwriters like
i follow a bunch of other people that do
what i do and
that comparison thing starts to kick in
and then like four hours later i'm in a
terrible mood and i'm like i wonder why
like
because
this like fantasy world i'm like
and you know i think that's just what it
is like i think that's just a part of it
um
but
i don't know i i it's definitely
complicated and like there are so many
days i wish
i think it can get overwhelming um when
it feels like you have to just wear
one million hats
as an artist now it's like
i can't i feel like i sometimes can't
just like focus on
writing a song like it's like you write
a song and then how do you mark it and
then how do you put it on tick tock and
like what's going to be the most
effective strategy and like
you have to like wear so many hats and
then it just starts taking all the magic
out of this thing you made because
it's just you're the one like i wanted
to try and remain as pure for me as
possible and like once it's like so this
song's sort of touching on
um like relationship problems like what
kind of relationship problems do you
have like
like talk to someone about it and like
promote the song that way and you're
just like ew like this is now all
gross like yeah
and so yeah there's a lot of layers to
it and i just
i try to like do as much as i can um and
i just kind of accept the fact that it's
like
sometimes it's gonna feel gross
sometimes it's gonna feel tiring
sometimes it's gonna feel like i can be
doing a lot more and i'm missing
opportunities like
um
but it's just kind of one of those
things that i am like
if i
you know i i'm an independent artist so
like i don't have a massive team with
millions of dollars behind me so
i'm just like i have to do this i have
to like you know
make this part of my career so how can i
do it in the healthiest way for me
personally and not like look too much
around it like what works for someone
else yeah well i'll say that i think you
do a great job with it i do feel like
your social media just doing research on
you reads authentically as you and you
have a good sense of humor about it and
you don't seem obsessive about it you
don't seem cookie cutter about it like
it just does feel authentically you uh
which is why i always like to ask people
that seem to from afar have a healthy
relationship with social media what they
actually think about it yeah but it is
yeah i'm with you the same thing that
it's like a love-hate relationship and
learning the balance of it is so much
easier said than done in
in practice but
i'm also
um
like in my early 30s so like i didn't
grow up with it like yeah i didn't have
it when i was in high school
to be that it is now and
i think that's helped me not
like i don't even understand what it's
like for younger kids now like it's so
much a part of your
identity like what do you present like
yeah seems like very overwhelming to me
and i don't know i think that help my
age helps a little bit with just being
like
okay yeah this is like a thing but i
don't
and it can be stressful but i don't know
i just yeah i had that you do yeah i'm
with you that you do remember your life
without it
for all of you barely
one time i didn't think about like how i
would post something
everything that happens
gen z will never have that experience
god bless i'm sorry
[Music]
um okay now i'm gonna ask you the two
questions ask every single guest that is
on the podcast
um the first is who alive or dead would
you like to throw cold spaghetti at
oh my gosh
um
and this i will say just as a caveat so
it takes a little bit of the pressure
out of it that it's just whoever in this
moment right now comes to mind i like to
think that this is an answer that
changes frequently for people right
because i feel like if it's cold if
you're throwing cold spaghetti at
someone you
maybe don't
like them
it's truly your intention it can be
celebratory it can be a prank it can be
for fun it can be for
good or it can be for evil
okay well maybe
it would be
um
maybe it would be like ashley olsen uh
or mary kate or both
and maybe it's
um
maybe it's fun like we're having dinner
together and we're so close
that it's like
oh my gosh
a girl and you just throw
a little toss and they're like
you're crazy
i'm a big mkna stan oh
same same i like that answer i i hope if
it happens i get to be a fly on the wall
when it goes down
i'll hit you up for the hang thank you
uh the other question i ask every single
guest is to tell us
your worst pants shooting story or like
a bathroom emergency situation
however
you can only use three words or
like small phrases to describe the event
so for example
mine is college
jogging front lawn
yes questions
okay
um
let's see let's see let's see let's see
and it doesn't have to be
pants [ __ ] it could be any sort of
bathroom
crisis
emergency
all right gosh
the i'm trying to think of how to
um
i feel like we get a little insight into
your songwriting creative process right
now too it is it's a lot of okay
okay
let's see
a few years ago okay
casting office
oh wow
wow
yeah oh that's a tough situation
nerves
herbs really
amplify yeah
the body does what it wants
no there's no stopping
it's the most inconvenient of time oh
well
but i made it through that's good and uh
i assume you got the part oh no no
but not because of that i don't think
although now i'm rethinking no reaction
it could have been like well
in the house
in hindsight
that would have been my downfall uh now
we have a section of the podcast called
deep and hot uh where i've prepared a
deep question for you
and i'm curious about uh your hot take
on kind of like a topic ish that we have
for you
so
me
this is uh we're getting your brain
going if you do get deep enough in
therapy here we go
okay
uh deep question for you is when do you
think it's better to walk away
in general in general i guess i would
attribute this for you in terms of like
creative endeavors have you ever found
yourself
getting to a point where you're like
this either this collaboration or this
song or this idea like at what point do
you realize like i have to abandon this
hmm
[Music]
i mean
for me i guess i think
i don't know like what comes up is like
me thinking about yeah if i'm working on
a song or if i'm working towards
something
i and i really want it but it's just not
working out i'll
put
so much effort in i'll
i'll just like
squeeze every
bit of effort and put it into something
and be like it has to work yeah
it's like feeling just like it's not
clicking or it's just not
working
yeah and you put like so much effort and
focus and like obsession into it um
then
i'll let it go like yeah but i i mean
maybe like to a bad degree like will
obsess over so like if i'm just like no
it has to work it has to be this certain
way
um
so yeah you sound like someone that
doesn't like to give up on something no
yeah which is very admirable
yeah i think i think so but i think i
could stand to like what i'm sure what i
try to get better at is like loosening
my grip on things it's like there's so
many different paths and ways you can
get to something you want and
if you're obsessively holding on to some
one idea or one way
uh you could maybe be keeping yourself
from getting there a different way or
finding something new
that you weren't looking for that you
end up loving or i don't know i mean i'm
i'm speaking about this now in terms of
kind of like life yeah path and like
what you do and
obviously and what this industry is
there's a lot of
i came up with one idea of like one
version of success one way to get there
um
and if it doesn't look exactly like this
then i'm a failure and i think
that's just not true and i've as i've
learned to kind of loosen my grip and be
open to different things it's opened up
you know new opportunities that i didn't
see coming or expect so great i guess
that's kind of what it makes me think of
yeah i think that's really important for
people to recognize too that there is
not always one way to do something or to
achieve something usually going to be
like usually your version of like what
you think you want or the way to get
there it's usually gonna look different
totally totally
um this kind of goes in line with this
the hot take uh
we're i'm curious about just your
thoughts on evolving as an artist
uh or you know kind of growing or
changing your aesthetic or
tone or quality or whatever it is what
are your thoughts on that
um
let's see
because you kind of mentioned earlier
that like uh
five years ago or so is when you felt
like you found your
voice and kind of
your style do you feel pressure to
evolve that over time or do you just
kind of pay attention to who you are
when you're creating and let that speak
for itself
i think i do i mean i i've definitely
evolved a lot as an artist over the past
few years i've done i've
released you know way poppier music i've
wanted to be this certain type of artist
and i think as i've um
kind of just embraced my instincts and
what comes a little more naturally
i've seen more uh
success that way like
not necessarily like uh
in terms of like oh more money or or
more numbers just like as
just creatively it feels like it clicks
it feels like oh this comes naturally to
me
easier to me this is kind of more second
nature like
why am i
you know i think i for a long time
resisted
writing about
my life
my like actual experiences because i was
like oh well
um i i don't
i want people to be able to
relate so what don't you have to kind of
like cater that to what you think people
want to hear
of kind of
just sharing
except or thinking that like oh if i'm
having these experiences and thoughts
and fears and like
uh insecurities probably
a lot of other people are too so why
don't i kind of write about that and
um
know that it will speak to whoever it's
supposed to yeah instead of like forcing
it and
um
that really opened up i think a lot for
me because i think it gave me more
confidence to like if i have a thought
during the day or
or a
view about something uh
maybe that's what i should be putting
into my music instead of
something that i think people want to
hear yeah does that make sense like
totally that it's not like a hallmark
card that you're an actual person that
is experiencing something
and as a human being
yeah i think you can just um so that's
what i think about as i
if you think about evolving as an artist
for me it's just like how do you kind of
keep getting closer and closer to that
like
core you yeah the thoughts only you can
have because you know
we're all unique we everything we're
going to create even if it's about
similar things it's going to have a
different feel to it and i think for a
long time i was like well i can't talk
about this because everyone else is
talking about it or everyone has already
been said sure i think just letting go
of those things and just trusting that
trusting your instincts trusting your
uh
thoughts and your
what you like like i i try to like what
would i want to hear in a song
what would i like to hear said or or
expressed and how can i do that through
my music um
so i don't know i think my goal is to
just kind of keep
doing that more and more and like
stripping away these kind of like uh
walls i put up of like
oh i want this certain thing or to be
a certain way like how do i just
kind of keep peeling that away
well the therapy is nothing but helpful
it is it's very helpful
um
we've reached the end of the podcast
this has been so lovely to talk to you
um before we wrap up completely we like
to give our guests a little token of our
appreciation and that is a personalized
horoscope from us to you
uh and we are not astrologers i dream at
all so if you don't mind reading it
aloud to the class that would be
wonderful let's just put it in the chat
okay here we go
okay
scorpion of the stars your ruling planet
mars will move into capricorn near the
end of this month which means it's time
to put action behind your thoughts and
words no more waiting for things to
happen a year from now
hey
i get it i get it i see what you did
there that's out there i love my song
all right all right point taken i'll get
my act together
your act sounds pretty together um oh i
do a good job of making it seem like
it's great
for people that don't know where can
they find you where can they listen to
the music where can they get access to
you
most stuff uh my music instagram all
that um it's just my name caitlyn tarver
so
if you pop that into google or spotify
or apple music or wherever i'll probably
come up and
just don't be alarmed if you find really
old photos of me
from like 2005 like just
just trying to like oh yeah we didn't
even get into the big time rush of it
all right
um but yeah you'll probably see some
big-time rust stuff pop up
and you know just be
just be supportive please yeah
and then maybe you'll be out in some
live shows over the course of this year
who knows i'm uh i'm actually opening up
for a band in the spring uh they're
called johnny swim so we have a tour
booked we have the date set great it
already has gotten postponed once so you
know where fingers crossed we're
crossing our fingers
um
so that'll be uh in march and april so
yeah i'd love for ever anyone to come
out and listen to the music if you like
it come see a show i'm hoping to play a
lot more shows this year so yeah awesome
thank you so much this has been great
yeah this has been so fun thanks for
having me of course guys go check her
out get into all the music see the live
stuff etc etc get into therapy if you're
so inclined yeah
and we'll see you guys next time on
another episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music